good morning everyone
happy Thursday welcome back to the
morning toast a special edition of toast
we have a very special co-host today a
fan favorite
Darrin oh my god and you call me special
twice so I feel I feel double special
today I'm so excited to be back here
we're so excited to have you and more
than that the toasters are so excited to
see you back on there's your fan base is
they are the most supportive people like
I was having a really crappy day and so
many people are like so excited for
tomorrow can't wait to see you I just
was like filled with love oh man we feel
that way all the time and we yes we
always like take like five minutes of
every show just to talk about how the
toasters are everything and like they
really are they really are I'm so glad
you've experienced because it's hard to
explain to people it's but it's so
random it's like a little random act of
kindness and last time I was on with
Claudia she made fun of me for my
Instagram so I was like I need to story
more things and so she had texted me and
so many toes was like I see you're
giving us more premium content I was
like just for you guys just so funny
no you're in serum is premium mostly
because your handle is everything carpe
Darian thank you which is just my name
backwards everyone thinks it's like so
clever which it is but it really is just
like my middle initial is e and last
names carp there we go
Wow yeah oh I thought it was like you
were just taking carp carp eh I was
doing like carpe diem but like it also
works out perfect that's really great
handle I like thank you it's nice when
things work out you know not everyone
can be as clever kismet kismet very much
so so we have a very special show
because Darin is here and because
obviously we're gonna hit you with the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and then you are
an expert on all things Bravo so we are
going to take your brain I have so many
questions about we're Honi and I just AM
or so one behind the scenes questions
okay to like I just want to know as
someone who is an insider what your
opinions are because definitely
something that cloudy and I struggle
with is like we takes eyes on you know
some of the key issues and we feel like
we're on the rock like we don't know
what's the right side so I'm curious to
know that's why we were silent like ten
minutes before going on with you guys
because we were like we don't want to
talk to each other we're saving it all
for you we are
about Carol and I found out the Darrin's
team Carol and I was like don't don't
explain like I need to understand why on
the show yes so we will get into that a
little bit later recapping all of Bravo
right now including southern charm I'm
shook as hell great I was at the Reunion
there was like a lot to digest this is
actually this is very like southern
charm reunion asked like break colors
with a little green I feel like Patricia
would like this set she would love it
she's growing on me actually I
you need like a Craig pillow in each of
these chairs and I'll be fine we really
did thank you and we will and they feel
like we can even if we have to like buy
them wholesale he would love it oh my
god and he he could use like clipart
little chat yeah just like palm tree
isn't like your face is like like
honestly the one that he was gonna make
for Patricia that was two palms and two
dogs
looks like Co Claudia's dog I thought it
looked like waka Andy's dog and I was
like did he just take a clip art of walk
I like I'm so confused
so it's perfect he should have woman
that 1 2 nd he gave him a crab's pillow
he did a significance behind it or it
was just a style that he liked I think
it was just a style he liked it's
currently on his couch in his office but
it matches the red because his couches
are red the crabs are red so maybe there
was like a matching theme there perhaps
yes look let's go with that so much to
digest so much should I just including
the fast side stories you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast so let's just get
right into them talking about the same
four people we talk about every day
because no one else wants to step up to
the plate and do something interesting I
feel like we have to I agree I'll strip
on the show free Jackie you know I will
you know and honestly you could because
this is a web show yeah okay this first
story actually was really crazy Kim
Kardashian begs Tristan Thompson to
unblock her on social media so if you
follow Kim you saw her in stories last
night where she is at Chloe's birthday
party which looked so lit and like
low-key and ideal yes it was my perfect
perfect party perfect evening no one's
there and everyone's having a good time
and it looks like I'm drinking there's
music playing there's a fire pit and
like the sun's going down and you like
they weren't wearing a lot of makeup
which is just like such a good vibe
it's the it's like Laguna Beach it
reminded me of that a little bit it was
very very chill I loved it totally I
hope they were filming but during the
party Kim asked Christian if she if he
could shoot him block her on Instagram
following his cheating debacle and
calling The Situation's so [ __ ] up on
national TV all right guys it's Khloe's
birthday should I ask this guy to
unblock me Kim quipped on Instagram for
Khloe's birthday will you please unblock
me Tristan who was laughing responded
it's only right I got you
anyways the insa story continues he
unblocks her finally finally also Kim
saw his list of black people and Malika
and Khadijah were also blocked Khloe's
best friends like how shady are you does
Chloe not care honestly I think she has
like way bigger fish to fry with him
that like that's not even on her radar
right of course but like his list I mean
I just want to know like I want to know
everyone on that list and I want him I
want to be blocked by him no total like
that's my dream and then be unblocked
yes on Chloe's birthday that I'm closer
yes anyways what a great gift for coming
I hope that means that like everything
is they seem to be having a good time
they seem to be having a good time they
seem to be happy yeah and she had like
responded to some haters on Instagram
like saying you don't know what goes on
in our household like in terms of
forgiving Tristan
right and you know what I'm just gonna
like choose to accept that they've
worked it out we're working it out and
most people don't know what goes behind
closed doors and like everyone is a
different relationship so just like if
she's happy Muslims out there and like
she has her baby right really what she's
wanted for so long true true
what do you think about the name true I
don't love it but that's just because I
think it's so often used and I'm like oh
I don't know really
yeah and that nine terms of a name I
just feel like oh yeah that's true like
true like it just feels I don't know
yeah naming your kid like meme like I
don't know right like they it just feels
like a overused term already but it's
really pretty and it is and apparently
like meek Chris's grandfather or someone
of Chloe's like great-grandparents name
was nickname was true or something like
that
okay so it has like family it has
seems to it yes I always want to know
like the Kardashian kid names coming out
with like Chicago and st. and all that
stuff like I just they're fastened
what's your favorite name Kardashian kid
name
I think I don't know like I kind of like
North I me too
okay thank you North is really just like
a dope name like hey I'm north like I
like you can't really nickname it no no
one's going her no like that's also kind
of a cute they call her nori which is
cute which is cute for a child but I
like North it has it's dignified I agree
and it's like she's taken the world by
storm II know but like I really mean it
like that
nor I could not say that but she really
like hat like North West she's like an
institution that's it that's a [ __ ]
name North West totally named right
there you know what's really crazy and
not talked about enough is that Kim Sun
st. has the same name as Kathryn and
Thomas's son and I believe that Kathryn
and Thomas did it first see yes yeah
because st. is will he turn one or two
and on southern charm - yes so that was
around the same time yeah and I doubt
either one of them are stealing from
each other I feel like it was organic on
their own but you know you were to God
if the Kardashians took it from southern
charm that would be my most premium
content ever you really never know you
never know I actually love the name st.
everything gets really cool but I
actually think Kathryn and Thomas's son
is like adorable both of their children
are so so cute
so I can't wait to talk about all things
southern charm yeah I'm loving Kathryn
the season okay I guess yep - your fix I
can't get to your fastball I guess I
guess we'll just get in - yeah I have
been like ride or die for Kathryn since
season one and like oh really yes and
even when she was going through all of
the things that she was going through
like I understood why like and how that
could happen in like I just was so
frustrated for her and like even with
like and I love Cameron everyone loves
Cameron but like there were a few
seasons where I just felt like she was
on the wrong side of history in terms of
Kathryn
yeah her and Whitney like just like not
being nice to have Herman like she was
obviously going through so much and just
trying to like do
best that she could yeah and I'm so so
glad that there has been justice hurt
after in the season and like tenfold
major and I will say there is justice
for Kathryn at the reunion that lady
Cameron acknowledges like maybe being on
the wrong side of history I think now
that she's a mom it's a little bit
different she's getting a different
perspective but justice for Kathryn this
entire season she's really like a role
model she really is she's a success
story yep she is and and Thomas Ravenel
is unraveling and as well he should but
what's crazy is we've seen like her
whole journey on TV like there was
children like she met Thomas on TV like
their whole and young she was young
she's just like it was a full-blown
adult me I didn't even think she could
drink legally no yes she was like 20 I
want to say like 23 24 or maybe
something like that yeah maybe 25 she
was young and so it's like really nice
20 she's 26 now so then she must have
been 23 yeah yeah which is like young as
hell to be on a reality TV 12 hours a
day doing this over and over having
children having your whole public having
an old private life in public like she's
really turned around and it's quite nice
to see ya justice justice has been
served by cavil is way too far but I
feel like so many people who have
started seven time from the beginning
yeah it's like such it's nice for them
it's like comes full circle you know I
think she said the biggest
transformation in terms of like how she
presents herself in all of Bravo like I
can't think of a bigger transformation
that quickly that's happened that's such
a juxtaposition of what she was two
seasons ago and like the audience
completely cuz the audience might win
over
yes I imagine right I know as a part of
the audience you you are our audience
right you know like and she just totally
turned the tables she should write
Turning Tables part two with Teresa
Giudice turning the tables okay I mean a
little bit more Kardashian news Kendall
Kendall Jenner might have already moved
in with her new man Ben Simmons the pair
were pictured leading a $25,000 a month
rental but they still haven't confirmed
their romance I don't know I don't think
this means that they've moved in
together I feel like maybe they just got
like an air B&B for the weekend yeah
we're like they were going looking at a
property together but not necessarily
like buying it and move
and having babies yet like we don't that
doesn't mean anything
agreed and also like she was making out
with Anwar not three weeks ago right so
I mean listen things change all the time
things can happen in three weeks look at
Pete Davidson an ariana grande very true
bringing it all back I think it's funny
that they were at a $25,000 rent but
when I think Sonja Morgan is renting her
townhouse for like thirty five thousand
twenty five thousand thirty five
thousand so we know that she's not at
Sonja's townhouse but she should be and
Sonia is another one who was having a
moment and what she's doing to her house
I think is brilliant yeah well I mean
she she need any $35,000 a month yeah no
she needed to renovate it in general
just for like her health
yeah but he's ridden she need to sage
the whole goddamn thing but like it's
genius like so many like fans who have
that money to spend are gonna stay at
her home and like she's gonna do really
well I hope she's gonna do I mean that's
like a massive it's a massively nice
house in the Upper East Side like if you
can afford 35 K a month do it and
gorgeou you get to be in Sonja Morgan's
house yes and document like every little
oh I had sex there oh I had sex there
I'm in what are we doing let's just do
it
I know and maybe there's like a week
rental we could like do the morning
toast for a week outside Sonja's
townhouse dun dun dun okay well maybe
they should move into Sonia's townhouse
speaking of yeah quick relationships
wait I just want to go back to add more
Hadid for a second because of course it
goes back to bravo Bravo David Foster
Yolanda
lemons what was the what was the pulse
like at Bravo when Kendall and Anwar
were spotted hooking up like did anyone
see that like what did you guys think I
don't remember anyone seeing it coming I
think we were all kind of excited that
it's all like that it all relates back
to Bravo like it's just funny just like
the whole community of it you know we'll
find out like some random person in
Europe is like the biggest Derrida fan
and we just freaked out cuz we're like
wow really we're a world organization
here we liked it I mean it wasn't it
wasn't crazy I don't think anyone was
like pissed off or you know whatever but
we were all very excited I don't really
expect to us it really does
okay so all the details on Ariana's
grandees karaoke birthday party with
Pete Davidson yeah you see videos she
they were actually being really cute
yeah they're cute they are cute they
were singing Evanescence which was a
beautiful song for them to sing because
she was singing the high parts then he
was doing like the screen mouth parts
yeah well cuz I don't think he's the
best singer no and she is so I really
glad that they like understood their
roles and a karaoke birthday party he's
like good clean fun it's good clean fun
and I'm actually surprised that they
would do it that feels really being and
fresh and like low-key to me for them to
do yeah I still can't really get over
their height difference like I'm still
really trying to process it all does he
do you know he's like 6 4 Wow and she's
like 5 foot but he's looked taller
because he's like 100 pounds so lanky
and she's tiny yeah she's like yeah
she's at your size like tiny person and
that's yeah I am NOT a tiny person and
that height difference is like really
bothers me like she comes up to his like
thigh that's so good oh my plan you 6 3
5 feet that's very good that is a 15
inch different that I believe in same
well she always says wear big heels I
could probably get for 3 or 4 inches and
then she wears like a headband with cat
ears I gave her like another 200 okay
that's smart and her pony gives her like
another 5 so she's basically 6 oh she's
taller than they have been really
low-key actually like they just like at
Whole Foods and Chelsea like even though
the only thing that's not looking about
is that she's like always stepping out
in like full hair and makeup look
sweatshirt in the summer thigh high
boots fine yeah I usually hipster chic
in a weird way ya know I appreciate her
dedication to the glam yes like it's
very Kardashian of her yes Pete Davidson
could use some of that he really good
down in the chair like just like touch
it up a little bit touch it up yeah just
like well speaking of Antony from queer
I was at yes the birthday party and the
queer eye guys were on watch what
happens live yes they were past week and
I want to hear all about it and also I
want tan to give Pete Davidson a little
sprucing up which he is we reported
yesterday he's dude he's helping him
dress for the wedding
oh thanks so don't you love when like a
things make sense
cuz I could see him wearing like a white
suit like shorts with like sneakers you
know like that's so Pete David he just
like throws on whatever he needs a
little makeover you guys and he needs a
little jvn in his life do you think
they're gonna last forever and ever I I
really so this is what I'm saying you
believe in love I believe in love like I
love love truly and for them to be
engaged like so quickly makes absolutely
no sense so the only reason I can think
of without like going down a dark path
is that they're so in love there's so
many RB they're meant to be the one they
knew love at first sight like this is it
for them so like with that said like I
believe I have to believe that like
they're gonna I mean I don't know about
forever and ever because like people
change and if they're still very young
but I think I've have to believe that
they very much loved each other would
you have gotten engaged that quickly was
that that's a great question I feel like
at six weeks you're like still like so
in a bubble that that's like actually
the perfect time to get engaged it's
like the floor mats right right because
you don't like know the person and then
it's like four months later you're like
oh [ __ ] you're like oh man this person
so so maybe that's where they're at and
actually oh that would actually make
sense them getting engaged that quickly
rather than like three months yeah
because your girl at the height of the
honeymoon that's six weeks and you don't
know and like everything is perfect but
you feel like it's been a long time
right and you're just like we're never
gonna get into a fight like I can't wait
for their first fight I wonder what
they'll fight about oh my god I don't
know but I just I hope it's good it's
juicy I hope and I hope that we find out
about it yes but we believe in love but
yes no but all couples fight no
relationship is perfect correct
definitely so the queer i yes men we're
on watch what happens live the nicest
men ever I just caught up with it last
night I was so excited yes
to watch how what was it like behind the
scenes just I mean it's like fabulous
like that sounds like a very like
overused term I think it Bravo but it
just it felt like them coming home cuz
that's really where they got like the
entire franchise of queer I got started
on Bravo like that broke Bravo that in
Project Runway which is also coming back
yes so it feels very like throw back a
little bit and even though it's some new
guys it was just the vibe Andy gets a
with them so well they're his people
it's just really nice and they're super
stylish yeah they are I didn't realize
that Annie had produced the first yes
the original query so that came on when
I said you have been at Bravo for seven
half years that was like just as I was
coming on to it so they had just like
we're I was already off the air by the
time that I came on but that was his
like first breaking out in the mold of
like producing something for Bravo that
was crazy so it's really full circle to
have like the new cast members oh yeah
and Karim oh actually like yeah
auditioned for queer eye because he saw
that it was coming back on watch what
happens live yes that's so crazy
again it all relates back to bra it
really does who is your favorite I
really like Antony I also look like my
gay cousin
and like almost too with tea so I really
just like feel like he's like my little
brother and Khurram oh I've watched
forever lately yeah he's been on he was
on in the real world I think yeah I
watched him that season then he was on a
few mtv things cuz I watch MTV so I've
sort of been in his ether a long time
but you know when queer I first came out
they were like Darren you have to watch
it because every like I'm crying over it
I was like you're crying they were like
the transformation just makes sense I
was like okay fine I watch it like I
definitely got teary-eyed in two percent
it's not the same thing that it was like
you'd think that now 2018 gay marriage
it feels like everybody could be gay it
still felt relevant it was oh nice so
relevant so timely and I think like so
well done Claudia and I had a very long
discussion about this like course how
they touch on issues and just like such
a way that's so well done yeah and I
feel like everybody feels like
represented and spoken for yeah it
doesn't feel like a superficial show
it's no deeper than that it's more than
it's not just like where you're here
this way like it's a whole
transformation of just on the inside out
how you carry yourself and that's that's
mage that's me I haven't watched season
two yet because I'm saving it me too I
haven't I haven't been I'm gonna like
binge bin of course I get once I start
like I can't stop I'll probably do it
this weekend yeah but I've just been
taking it actually sack started watching
last night without me and like it was I
was like dude that we were watching we
watched a first season together like
that's literally my definition of
cheating I was so shocked I really I I
just I just remembered that right you
yelling
like I was just like what are you doing
like I was like you're not watching
queer I think because he was has been
binging the office and I've been binging
Mad Men like so we've been like got our
own things but I didn't realize the
office had just ended and he just like
went right over you they need to have
like a sit-down conversation how are you
get officially wet he's out of control
just so inconsiderate I can't anyway is
a nice shed and I went this next story
is really crazy yeah um I don't know how
into or like concern you are about
Scientology but Claudia like can't get
over I could go down a rabbit but we
were meeting see areas like that's my
favorite thing in the entire world okay
because this story is wild yes
the Daily Mail reports that Scarlett
Johansson fires back at
ex-scientologists who claims that she
auditioned to date Tom Cruise I didn't
know that like that oh I know about
auditions - dating Tom Cruise really
yeah like I heard Katie was like in
there that makes sense I mean when I
remember when they got together early do
remember that was so straight it was
just oh they're together and in love
well yeah it was it was and I had the
biggest crush on heating homes because
like Joey Potter was like my girl
growing up like she was the reason I
knew I was gay I'm just like I love you
so much so that when she got married to
Tom Cruise I was like devastated and I
went down this huge dark like rabbit
hole and then I found read all about
Scientology okay so the story goes that
the 33 year old Beauty fired back after
ex-scientologists Brendon take he told
megyn kelly today on Wednesday that
she'd audition to date a Lester Tom
Cruise in the wake of his February 2001
split from Nicole Kidman the very idea
of any person auditioning to be in a
relationship is so demeaning the ghost
in the shell' star told The Hollywood
Reporter I refused for anyone to spread
the idea that I lack the integrity to
choose my own relationships well but
you're saying that people do audition
did Hollywood right like I feel like
that's a known thing that people do that
you know let's go on about it the
arrangement right and like hey I have to
go to a red carpet event and they don't
want to go by myself so like let me
bring a hot model or a hot this or hot
that like that is what Hollywood it is
right that's not surprising I understand
her being offended by it though by being
like looped in Leo's people especially
if it's not true I mean especially if
it's true but if it's not true then yeah
I mean I could get her one
for herself I totally agree I'm like no
one wants to be dragged into the
scientology mess that like nathan you I
mean I'm obsessed with Elizabeth moss
like Handmaid's Tale madman watch I'm
season by Madden right now I just found
out she's a Scientologist
hey it really crushes my soul like it's
the one thing that I just I can't get
over I cannot get over it I can't love
her because of this one thing and it
feels bad I feel bad but I just I love
her work but I don't understand her
being in Scientology like I love John
Travolta so much but he is like king
scientist I mean he's Tom Cruise he's
like the other I know it I don't I don't
understand I don't understand either his
wife was on watch what happens live and
she's like the nicest person and she was
just like John is so sweet John us with
this and I'm like she must know we never
asked her about Scientology but she must
know like all the rumors that circulate
about him everyone that talks about
Scientology like I just wonder how she
deals with that in her real life I agree
like how much of Scientology affecting
their day-to-day I'm sure it's
everything at least John is married tom
was not so maybe there was like some you
know they were being his like gay mafia
hold back I don't know but it's like
bizarre do you watch Riverdale I don't I
know and II had an appearance he wants
me to binge you should it's on my list
okay I know I'm gonna ban the pressure
on you I know it's like the most
attractive people in the world are on
that show and it's I think you would
really like it okay because also and the
first few episodes of the first season
it's like you're gonna feel like what am
i watching like it feels like fake like
weird ABC Family like weird
yes but it really it gets so good okay
it's two seasons it's two seasons so far
the second season has like 22 episodes
so it's really long and it's just really
wonderful but there is a character I
think Hermione Lodge yes he's a
Scientologist as well so when Andy was
on I know that he was with her mind yes
right okay yes okay it all comes back to
me now yes yeah yeah that was so crazy
when Andy was at me he was so excited he
was freaking out he was so excited they
were filming in Vancouver he was like
I'm gonna be on Riverdale oh my god
cause Marcus Willis is like his really
good friend yeah
and so I was arranging it for him and
he's like do you watch it I was like
no he's like just read the script you
know we were only reading the script
together I was like I need to binge this
I need a binge this is now when you
watch it you're gonna like and this
always happens to me from a guest on the
show who I'm not familiar with their
work then I'll go home and like watch it
or something yeah I'm like oh my god and
now I have all these questions and like
a need to know all these things seeing
him on unbreakable kimmy schmitt last
season also was weird for me because I'm
a huge fan of that show and like he was
because um djenka Kowski was like
auditioning to be a housewife and the
way that he had handled I was like I
it's so it's so meta
that's amazing it was great I'll break
will give me [ __ ] is amazing except this
Cudi and I were saying this the last
have you watched the new season yeah
it's only six episodes there and it's
the last season and they're coming out
with six more are they yeah as part of
like the second half of the last season
thank God the first six those six were
like I agree and they dedicated one
whole episode to the fake documentary
right and I was just like oh I don't
know I like the inner plate I this is my
favorite like more of him like have him
sing more song so Jacqueline is awesome
anything you give it I love her so much
she is Bravo like she is Bravo you know
i know i wit i I also just love Jane
yeah as an actress me too in everything
no 30 rock she made it she made 35 in
the Tropicana commercial yeah you know
so role in a lifetime like we're working
out with like her hot black trainer I'm
like this
me too I mean it's amazing okay
Tropicana right yeah that's funny next
story is so sad Queen Elizabeth falls
ill and cancels an appearance
no I know I hope she's okay but she's
just feeling under the weather which I
mean she didn't be too much hurry home
about but luckily Angelina Jolie showed
up in her stead I don't know if it was
actually in her said but Angelina Jolie
went to st. Paul's Cathedral at the
dedication service and the Queen was not
there but then it got me thinking about
Angelina Jolie
yeah and just like her role she has been
around recently right like in terms of
like being in the press in the spotlight
exactly I hear things about her and Brad
Pitt sometimes but right yeah she's been
very quiet and now she like steps out in
like a little oil I kind of like that
but she's like a full philanthropist now
like a full humanitarian
moved past her just her acting career
totally but I just wondered like why now
and also why didn't you go with Royal
Wedding then if she's clearly like in
royal circles yeah I don't know why she
wasn't at the Royal Wedding that could
have easily been though something with
her kids something in her career like
that could have just and maybe she wants
to stay out of the spotlight because I
feel like the Brad thing really messed
with her messed with their whole
relationship and I think when you have
kids you don't really want that to be a
big you know you don't want it to affect
it as much as it is and everyone is
obsessed with Angelina Jolie and Brad
Pitt like you couldn't get a more
Hollywood couple now I really couldn't
that's Holly when I first read it that
it was that they were divorcing I was I
like didn't believe it for a second yeah
it was like Jennifer Aniston is pregnant
again like right just like fake news
headlines and then TMZ reported it in
this you were like that's official yeah
that's worth they happily the Bible told
me it was like they you have court
documents like that's that it's it was
it was kind of upsetting so you're like
if they care if the two most beautiful
people in the world like no there's
granted there's more to marriage than
that but it can't make it work then like
what am I gonna do
right I'm [ __ ] right and especially
like uh Andy hurts me I could we've
heard so many weird things like about
their relationship now and I mean I
don't know whose side you've taken in
the matter it's tough though because I
don't really look there was a whole
thing where he was like addicted to weed
and I'm like can you really be a dick
like is this just like who cares that he
smokes pot like right and that affecting
the kids I don't know like I read
something that he was kind of abusive
and a way to them which I would never I
don't condone but like is that true I
don't I don't know I read he got drunk
on a plane great and was like yelling I
don't know see that's the thing I don't
know there's not enough specific details
about it for me to really take a side
like I love Angelina I just I really
really love who she is I usually like
all of the work that she does she's
super smart she's a good philanthropist
but I don't like so he was yelling on a
plane like my parents yelled at me
before like what were they saying I've
been playing great like you to yell at
your children I certainly would have
taken it to better as a kid if my
parents had a PJ totally I would've been
fine
right you work very hard ya know and
also when things come out about each of
them it just makes you wonder like why
it's coming out I think it just makes
you question their motives in everything
there's too much there's not enough
detail but too many stories about it for
me to take a side I just hope the kids
are okay I agree yeah but they all have
each other there's so many of them and
they're like wealthy like they'll be
fine yeah they'll be okay okay anyways
now that we have covered all the news of
the day yes Rob let's talk Bravo
because Mahoney last night was great
first of all I'm loving the grace
Mayflower in okay I literally asked HACC
if we could go next weekend and he said
no but okay but maybe I would think I
would rather go in the winter anyway I
like a winter vacation it's very home
are crimes
it's just romantic and warmer like a
summer vacation I'm like oh it's sticky
it's hot I don't want it you can let go
to the beach yes winter is like it's a
perfect time so you're loving your
loving the season
I'm loving the season like it's just
really crazy because I find myself not
knowing like who to trust who to okay
also like and that's I don't know how to
like trust my own judgment too because I
feel like for a long time Bethenny like
I was always been a crowd favorite but
like hazards been your favorite no but
I've always I've always liked her always
respected her I feel like but when she
like gets in fights she isn't know at
all like she definitely throws people
like you know when she should have to
fight with right when she was yelling on
suing about like the cheater brand a few
seasons ago like that was just like peak
Bethenny for me it's like why are you
going in on this girl like she'll never
she's never so she's not gonna steal
your brand and she doesn't know like it
was an innocent was no mal-intent right
no exactly
so now this season like to find myself
on her side it's just so interesting
because I do really like Carole I really
really like Tinsley which I know I don't
know if you get that a lot
no I tensley like the sweetest Bert like
she's sweet as pie no I'm and I just
like her on the show I think she's like
adds something that there's no needed
she's like the Eloise but like a Sonia
type person we're just kind of like life
is great but also she's a real
pretty-like
for her to be good friends with Carole I
think you have to be intelligent you
have to be frank good conversationalist
so in this battle I have we have chosen
team Bethenny Wow both of you both of us
and we can't believe that one it seems
like
we are like on an island here and the
way that it's edited the show we feel
like Bravo is taking Carol side and you
have really yes that is the most
shocking because and so many people feel
the opposite and more than that we are
surprised that Bravo State and Carol
side because Bethany is clearly like the
bigger housewife she's on another show
like she has more like so we were
surprised by the editing I mean let me
just say this season like what Bethany
single-handedly did for Puerto Rico was
unlike anything I've ever seen agree
like you deserve a Nobel Peace Prize if
that's what you're doing and chartering
private planes so aside from that
because that's just like such a
monumental thing the Ramona drama is
just in its own little bubble so let's
take the Puerto Rico thing out of it I
feel like so many people think Bethenny
gets a good edit like so many people I
feel like in general she does but in
this situation like she's not so what
don't you like about like do you not
believe Carole do you just not like how
she was treating Bethenny like what made
you turn I just I feel like I understand
like I can understand what happen
between them like they had a summer they
didn't see each other a lot
Carole is very close with Tinsley yes
Carol is doing things that she wasn't
like she's traveling she is like very
fashion II hair being with southeast
hints like we're not that there's
anything wrong with that that's
literally my biography but she wasn't
doing all of that before as much yeah
she was definitely more serious
converting her kitchen to like a
journalism room like yeah she was much
more serious so I understand how there's
a rip like there's a divide between them
but I think that's normal like
friendships ed and flow yeah and there's
and it's nothing to write home about no
like there was no bad blood but the fact
that they can't get on like solid
footing again is concerning and then I
think what does it in for me is like in
their interviews yeah it's very clear
that Kerala is still in the moment like
mad at Bethenny and going in on her
whereas Bethenny and her interviews is
like more reconciliatory if that is a
word I think they both want it deep down
like if like I was interviewing Dorinda
last night for my weekly pregame on
Bravo TV and we were talking about her
and I was like what is going on with
them and she's just like I feel like
they both
like its kind of eroded like at first
they were both like okay yeah we really
want to make this work and then it
didn't really happen they were like well
let's try again and then they were just
like you know what I'm too lazy they
like even make this happen like it just
has faded away and they're not the best
of friends and they both have such like
stubborn egos they're both so smart yeah
and Carroll can really a lot of people
can't give it to Bethany cuz Bethany
will come in and you'll attack you and
she's super smart and she's super witty
and she knows how to argue but Carroll
is like a thinker yeah like so when
she's not responding to you it's like
hard to read and I think that confuses
Bethany and so I think I think their
egos and their stubbornness or like
they're not connecting because of that
like neither one of them as well there
should be like you know what I'm sorry I
miss he was a friend and if one of them
just said I miss you was a friend but
baby didn't say that Bethany texted
Carroll saying send her picture and said
I miss you and the Carroll said that's a
lot so it's not over and they can you
see those texts though did you see that
no but the Carroll and then like we
don't they're all like so annoying
because it's like Bethany will say you
said this to me and Carol said no I did
it but then Carol doesn't say what
actually was said they're so like caught
up in the details they're arguing is
like really frustrating sometimes in the
same house like in carta Hania like just
apologize to each other like who cares
what it what it is I don't know if it's
like a jealousy thing though well and
perhaps because they're both like the
smart women of the group yeah and
they're both very self-aware which is
why when it came out that they were
fighting to begin with like there were
like stories in page six and I was like
I couldn't believe it because best
friends like who are both aware of the
public position that they're in like
don't like err each other's dirty
laundry or their own definitely so that
was what was really surprising is that
like the rift was real by the way
what do you think of Carol's fashion
this season um not here for it it's very
avant-garde to me it's very high fashion
I've always loved her like the past few
seasons I felt like she had the best
style of the women like yeah just always
dressed like so downtown cool effortless
and this season I don't feel that way
she was wearing like a tracksuit and
Connecticut that was that just was doing
nothing for me it what you were not
feeling it you're not
but you think that because Carroll and
Bethany are on the outs that Bethany has
force focused her efforts on Sonia and
has transformed Sonia yes so she's doing
good she's doing okay and you know what
if I were her I would do the same thing
because you need like a life raft in the
situation you need doing the same thing
with LuAnn
whoo right I think it's perfect timing
for that well I think LuAnn like needed
you know LuAnn have actually mean like a
quite a transformation this season like
cuz all of a sudden I mean the editing
has been amazing where she like slips
out of the cuffs and then comes back and
now she's like she's not drinking she's
you know she's having a great time she's
still the life of the party
that's what I love about LuAnn she's not
like down in the dumps we drink like she
feels good about it and she's still like
kicking it in a wig loving life so
excited to see her in that way she looks
amazing she just she was ready for carte
de hann yeah like she went in full force
and it was great to see but it's good
you know what I'm curious to see about
the reunion seeing what I think is gonna
be like LuAnn showing you Bethenny on
one side and the rest on the other like
we've never really seen that so this
divide this year is gonna be crazy and I
know that those riffs are still going on
because I suspected Carole a couple
weeks ago and shoes like yeah Bethenny
aren't really talking and the blog posts
say it all say it all yeah and I mean
like this is you know they're commenting
from a blog post about like an episode
that just happened so I'm like okay are
you guys like did you guys make up like
outside the camera she's like not really
and now it's like please don't make up
like say the further Union well yeah
exactly like what I want to see some do
they film the reunion soon we are
filming it in mid-july so yeah cool
three weeks oh wow okay you have to have
me on after that so I can give you some
of that gossip no definitely also
there's like a rift between Bethenny and
Dorinda and like Dorinda went in on
Bethenny in her blog yes but I feel like
because this season
Dorinda the way that it's come out
Dorinda has kind of been anti Sonja and
anti LuAnn and that's Bethenny's squad
this year so of course there's gonna be
a rift there and she's gonna like stick
up for her but I think the Nutcracker
incident what are your thoughts on like
Cuddy and I thought that was such a
nothing burger like Bethenny couldn't
have been more happy grateful jumping up
and down like clearly like over the
and she thanked her in the yes in the
berkshires and then at the house like
she was just you know what you can't
like script your your excitement I agree
when I first watched it I was like and
she said thank you like she's just
overwhelmed because like obviously Brynn
really wanted this goddamn Nutcracker
like she was just so happy that she did
it but I also know that you know the way
there's a lot more going on behind the
scenes than we really realize and I
think because Bethenny's reaction was so
grand it wasn't so big like she just sit
like this girl just donated like fifty
million dollars to Puerto Rico and she's
literally crying on the ground from a
nutcracker
I think Dorinda wanted something more
and I think no matter what because
Bethenny is who she is you want her
acceptance you want her approval right
even if you don't want to admit it who
doesn't want to be praised by Bethenny
like that that's a fact I want to be
praised by Bethenny I don't do anything
like I've always liked ethany do I look
pretty today like always so it's just
she just commands out attention and I
think Dorinda really wanted her to be
like thank you so much for doing this
for me
like I think she really wanted that
extra mile I get it it was a nothing
burger extra mile was there like she's
on the floor and yes I feel like
logistically what Dorinda did was get
Bethenny in touch with the the guy the
the Christmas guy yeah so in the burst
years when during the does that Bethenny
is like oh my god thank you like we're
getting the Nutcracker so then at
Bethenny's party she's thanking the guy
who brought all the way here like she
already thinks that Dorinda is it
already happened and then yeah you know
I think you're into really wanted more
praise and I think that she felt like
she got I don't think that was
indicative of there being a riff but I
definitely think that was the start of
like something major yeah no definitely
and it's really crazy but I honestly as
much as it's shocking yeah shocking it's
necessary in order for like the show to
move forward sometimes when everyone's
always in a good place like Beverly
Hills for example sometimes they write
one wants to get their hands dirty right
and it's kind of like backing away from
trauma but no one really wants to see
that right like I mean want to so I'm
grateful for this shift there and and
the shift this season I feel like it's
so different than any other season and
it it feels divided but also super
cohesive because no matter what like
even if LuAnn
on Bethany side and against Carol like
everyone supports her sobriety everyone
supports our no matter what
Ramona's all over the place it just it
it's a great great show it's a great
great I can't wait to see the boat oh my
god anyway so we just got the mid-season
trailer for Briony and it is it looks
insane so I was just saying to you
before the show like when we're honing
premier and I was like I'm so excited
this is great but I want to see like I
got arrested right we went been arrested
I'm like this is so great I'm so excited
but I want to see the boat like yeah
there's always a milestone to look
forward to for sure it is it looks
insane it is insane it is insane and I
don't mean that like oh my god there's
so many fights I mean the boat trip
itself is just absolutely crazy there is
a lot of toilet trouble I'll give you
that
lots of toilet trouble that's not very
girly like but that's what makes it fun
but everyone was like too sick to fight
but how like serious was it like did
they were they really like in fear like
for their lives yeah that's what they
mean I think there's a certain caliber
of trip like especially you know like
seasons 6 7 8 9 10 you've been doing
this forever they're like everywhere
they go for the most part is like
absolutely gorgeous you know maybe not
maybe not it's not all tequila Mexico
but everything is pretty high ends I
think when this kind of happened and
they got a parasite and it was very very
crazy they were scared they were they
were not they're normally not having
like toilet troubles on Real Housewives
of New York you don't take another level
it's legitimately another level did you
see the photo of the ladies at the
airport returning from the trip that
went viral where it's like Ramona's in a
wheelchair everyone's like sitting on
the floor they look like Ramona would be
in a wheelchair
of course like that's just that's who
she is bringing carted around like oh my
god do you know that so we're we love
Ramona we love everyone yeah and I we
just think Ramona looks so incredible
she looks she looks at the best of all
of them and as the oldest agreed and so
we went to her doctor dr. sharon DZ did
she got Botox by her last week my first
round was she amazing she was amazing
I'm obsessed
what did it feel like to get Botox for
the first time um it was so you don't
need Botox no I had like a frown line
here that just one Bob the line bothered
me and two I didn't want to be able to
like make that face because I
make it even when I wasn't angry and it
was giving me a case of RBF and I'm so
not an RBF kind you are not an RB other
you are smiles for days girl
thank you so I just really bothered me
and I wanted just the best yeah so it
hurt but the needle is like so so tiny
that it's like such a tiny puncture that
it's like how how this isn't gonna like
who actually hurt me you know it was a
weird feeling was very quick like
definitely got a little teary-eyed I was
like smiling the whole time I was so
excited
we was you know I'm after like did would
its well and then go down or was no it
was fine I had I bled a little bit which
is it like it's normal it's normal but
most people don't I just I guess I'm Oh
bleeder and like I had a little bruise
here but honestly I didn't mind the
Bruce because it reminded me of a good
time I had it I guess that is that is so
fantastic one of my best friends just
became a dermatologist she just she'd
just literally finished her internship
and I was like so in six months we can
all get free Botox right she's like
that's a good friend yeah I was like
you're my best friend that's why I've
stuck with you for all this time in bed
school speaking of dermatology we have
so many questions because you have the
most amazing skin thank you what is your
routine regimen products you can't live
without okay
the product that I can't live it out but
probably gives me the most dewy glow is
Bobby Brown shimmer brick
it is literally amazing it's probably I
don't know 50 75 bucks not crazy lasts
forever and I kind of just touch it up
it there's different palettes of it but
I have like a bronzer one that I kind of
just used as like a face Lightner do you
put a do it before your makeup or no I
do it it's kind of like my last step
your highlight your yeah it's basically
my highlighter I always take my makeup
off before bed like that is every time
you ask a dermatologist like the thing
outside of smoking and alcohol it's
taking your makeup off before bed
elemental it's what makeup remover duty
is key if I told you you'd be so
embarrassed my market for a new anyone I
literally use Vaseline what do you put
it I just take Vaseline on a tissue and
I just take my makeup off and then I was
like you got oh
especially my eye makeup and then I use
like a Neutrogena face wipe that my
girlfriend introduced me to that's why I
use the Neutrogena face folks but I
don't feel they're good for travel oh my
god they're like really
Triana episode about like beauty and
skin to Claudia and I and we were
talking about Neutrogena face whites and
how they're great like makeup remover
but someone now I need something a
little bit like stronger but when you're
traveling it's like manna from heaven
when someone gives you one it feels like
a face wash like you don't even need to
put water on your face you just so you
can go to best bed straight yes but I
use Vaseline always for my eyes that's
so interesting because I find that other
makeup remover when you use it like it's
like an oil it just doesn't get all of
it off Vaseline gets everything off and
you'd think that your eyes would be all
blurry and crazy which I'm sure most of
you probably think no it's great and
makes your skin super soft
it's cheap and it works super so just a
tissue and masley and I'm doing it I
swear to god it's just that that's only
thing that I use and then a new Georgina
face wave I use sebum ed as a face wash
which is like pH balance for your face
like a dermatology dermatologist
recommended it and then I just like put
on my healthy glow because you're so
glowy I like you oh my god last time I
was here and your sister took a picture
of me my face was this light it was like
this and I texted I was like you told me
that you were gonna put a filter on me
you told me you're gonna make me look at
she's like woo I made myself look good I
was like I will kill you and I wrote on
it I was like justice for me cuz my face
looks like an oil slick I was very upset
you have to make sure today we don't do
that I I would not do that to you but
it's so crazy because in person
your face looks perfect don't you then
say in pictures like that doesn't
translate but who like who cares it's
like I feel like looking great in person
is what actually matters it matters but
I just don't want you know if I'm taking
a picture with like a housewife I don't
want to look like I'm sweaty and gross
yeah because they look so elevated that
I just want to look normal
yeah I don't need to look like I'm
glamorous I just want to look not like
an oil slick
that's all that's fair thank you I don't
think you're asking for too much that
should that's it but the skin remedy is
very important skin is like very very
important to me and I hydrate agreed
cleanliness and hydration are the two
pillars of sync get your hair and I
don't smoke cigarettes there you go like
we're already like ahead of the game
yeah totally
okay now I'm gonna take a lot of viewer
questions because we have so many
questions through you um first of all
you'll have a podcast I do martinis
murder what are you working on right now
oh my god we work on so many things we
actually just updated another episode in
the mix called another shot were you
kind of keen to find out about me and
John our personal lives we take your
questions it's very fun we play games
and then we do a murder each week we're
doing a ton we actually recorded
yesterday about a murder that I had
never even heard of but that was very
popular with like this religion it was
it does Branch Davidians murder they
killed a bunch of people it was insane
we're gonna do Timothy McVeigh soon we
did Casey Anthony recently is there any
murder that you won't do
there's definitely murders that are hard
to do because of all the legal
stipulations of it like trying to do
JonBenet we did it but it was really
really really hard because he's still
alive and we don't want anyone suing us
it's it's pretty difficult because we're
because we're part of a network and we
have a lawyer on the line we can't
really say our opinion like we all have
our opinions on you can stomp a day
right right later than what I asked you
last time yeah but and I gave like you
know like it could be the brother but I
understand if the parents hit it because
you know you don't want to lose two
children at once like that's the PC
answer that's frustrated as opposed to
being like this as you did it it's
really hard I have my own opinions and
how do you feel about like Netflix shows
like making a murderer the staircase
have yet managed it done you watch this
air case entirely who do you think do
you think he did it I didn't watch it
you know I got a sailor oh you you
should watch it a lot of it is actually
just like legal kind of just watching
how the legal process works at first I
was like he definitely did it all the
blood that was there no one falls down
the stairs and has a blood bath no one
but by the end of it you're kind of like
could it have been one of those really
weird freak accidents that you're just
like there was me like there was
reasonable doubt like I don't think that
he should have been convicted even
though I think that he'd probably did it
I don't think he don't think there was
enough evidence oh my which is sad
because so many times you're like you
definitely raped her you definitely did
that but there's just not enough
evidence to convict and like we have to
trust the court system the way that it
is and it's really frustrating
that's so frustrating to use you saw
that episode of Kimmy
Schmidt where they're like trying to do
like a Netflix type documentary about
Reverend yeah and like trying to prove
his innocence that was really funny that
was very very meta
it was super meta that was very like
Geist II that hit it at the proper time
I'm a big I'm a bit I donate a lot to
the Innocence Project which basically it
it deals with the DNA evidence to
exonerate people who are on death row
and so I'm very I'm a huge advocate of
that so for me like evidence is really
really major and it's that makes it more
frustrating because they wish we could
almost just vote based on our feelings
but like how many people would be
innocent in jail because we feel like
they did something and they really did
it yeah and it's just like wrong place
wrong time
that's so tell you learn a lot by doing
the podcast so how do you prepare for an
episode on a case that you've never
heard of before I always so we basically
have like all of our research handed out
to us but a few days before I read it I
look online
I'll watch videos sometimes I watch a
documentary about it and then John and I
just kind of go like we don't talk about
the case separately because we both want
to come at it from our own angles and we
just kind of go and we riff and that's I
mean there's tons of research behind it
and again we have a lawyer on the line
we have to edit out anything that we say
that might be bad which happens cuz like
I make bad jokes sometimes I'm so hard
it's an you're talking about like a
really serious object yeah like I'm not
gonna cry
she was murdered like no one wants that
but they want to make a situation funny
without without also honoring the victim
it's a little bit difficult but yeah I
prepare I prepare on my own there are
some murders and I'm just so obsessed
with that I know that I won't need to
prepare because I know she's so much
about that yeah like girls Manson oh
yeah are you excited for the movie so
excited I mean any anything Manson
related with like the Hollywood Hills
and like all that stuff I'm just like
who's playing Sharon Tate isn't it I
heard him was maybe I hardly remember
that it was Hilary Duff but I think that
was false why did I think it was like
Margot Robbie because well first she was
like people were talking about her and
then Sharon hate sister said that she's
not pretty enough but and then I I feel
like I heard that she is playing
guarenteed sister said Margot Robbie was
not pretty enough to play
Sharon Tate is she blind cuz Margot
Robbie's like the best-looking yet of
you the best-looking woman in the world
like the
like no I know she's like my number one
like you can't get prettier than
Margaret green and she's a great actress
she would she would nail the role she
played Tonya Harding amazingly well and
she didn't even look attractive in it I
was like that was so crazy that was a
great that was a great movie that was a
great movie and I didn't see it for like
a few months yeah and I was very I've
seen Nancy all the way and I am so
ashamed to say but that movie like
really got me thinking like you're like
maybe Tonya's not so bad exactly but
think of how she grew up not that it's
an excuse to love someone's need look
like okay she didn't have the easiest
life she didn't know one was like
supporting her she was like white trash
and she like really changed she became
an Olympian that's amazing
totally yeah it's so it's not so black
and white no okay vibes here on the
morning toast this morning we're all
about positive toasty vibes going tell
us everything about Andy and John Mayer
and I want to know about the Andy
birthday special that was hosted by John
Mayer yes how did that come together
that was the hardest show to do because
everything was so surprised - Andy so
literally I had to like book his car and
I was like you're gonna go do the show
for your birthday we're not gonna say
the guests like it's a surprise for your
birthday was like okay he will he rolled
with the punches John and Andy had this
bromance like I've never seen Andy so
giddy happy than when he's around John
and when John walked out as you can see
from Andy's reaction he was like yeah
that was genuine like you can't fake
that he had no idea all the guests were
amazing like Andy probably would have
been happy with Dorinda but because John
took time out of his touring schedule to
be there like it was it was really
magical and his like ogee friends were
the bartenders yes I know those are all
of his like that's his squad yeah that's
what Claudia said cuz she has read all
of his books and so there was a huge
event those are like his friends that
have been with him when he was like a
little awkward Jewish boy in st. Louis
like they have Ryder dies and they're
all so nice to me like they're just
really genuine people he's got a great
squad around him that's great I feel
like he's a good mix of celebrity
friends and like real friends but that
makes him humble because someone who
just has celebrity friends I'm like no
no no no but you also like when you're
some of they like you must have some
interesting celebrity friends so you
must it's I think it's a really good mix
yes were there any other birthday
plans that you guys were toying with for
the for the big extravaganza I mean we
wanted I mean listen we wanted everyone
to kind of come through like cher Diana
Ross anyone major and big but he and
John Mayer just felt so right and you
know John Mayer has performed a number
of different times he was there actually
on Andy's actual 50th birthday that we
celebrated it was it was a really nice
dream it was a mixture of all of his
real friends and celebrity friends
thought that his celebrity friends
aren't real but you know what I mean and
then John Mayer like surprise
performance and it was it was heaven
that's so sweet
it was heaven and John is actually the
nicest guy like I introduced him to my
girlfriend my girlfriend was like
comfortable was my favorite song when I
was like 18 my girl feels like in her
mid-30s and he leaned over and sang it
in her ear and she cried like she was so
happy she was like I'm not well from
this I'm not well and just kept saying
I'm not well that's crazy like for two
weeks straight wouldn't talk about
anything John Mayer is currently in the
background of her phone so my boss and
my girlfriend are obsessed with this guy
I just have to lie like him just for
that like I just accept him for that
that's so sweet a sweetheart though he's
really kind okay I'm glad to hear it
I'll tell Claudia because she loves him
okay good and then she she I think she
knows that now he's really kind cuz he's
like been through a lot well circle he
definitely has relationship troubles
admittedly and he talks about it and
he's like it's so great to be friends
with Andi because it feels like no one
wants to be friends with me because of
my dating history but so unfair well it
is unfair because again like when
everything is in the spot like like you
just don't know I mean even watching
like we're housewives it's like you
don't really it's 80 hours of footage
for one hour of housewives yeah oh wow
so think about the 79 hours that you're
not seeing like that's crazy that's
crazy like think about all the other
things that have happened yeah you know
and maybe most of that is mundane but
the other stuff like there's juice there
and I think the same thing with like
Hollywood stories it's like we're Brad
and Angelina like you don't really know
well another epic Real Housewives to you
that we felt like we were on an island
yes Teddy versus Erica I would love to
get your professional opinion okay I
actually really liked Eddie I we love
Teddy we've had her on the show we were
with her a few weeks ago at a party oh
she's such a cool girl she's so like
normal she's beautiful and just like
sweet and
like just cool and down to her she is
one of those people that's actually
stunning in real life like she looks
pretty on camera yes yes yes but they
all do
but I've seen her completely dressed
down I've interviewed her for weekly
pregame she's real considering that
she's John Mellencamp's like [ __ ]
daughter like she's down to earth agreed
I don't think it's a facade everyone's
like oh she's just playing that for TV I
was like no it takes too much effort to
do that and she's constantly that way
through and through
I think Erika whom I worship and I love
and I think she's like her own special
soul and literally could run the world
you know I mean she makes she makes fun
that she's like a little bit cold and I
think when Teddy being so warm
it just it's you know like fire nice
yeah it's it's oil and vinegar as a
would say I think I was three says she's
like it's like oil and vinegar she's
like you mean water cuz I let me go
together yeah that's so funny so I I
don't think they can read each other and
that's what I think the real problem was
with that and I think Erica knows how to
you know be biting and I think when
Teddy said that thing and you don't talk
about here Erica's kids like you just
don't talk about her family and you can
tell she doesn't really want to talk
about it like she always wants to move
forward in her life as opposed to
looking back and so we think that's
gonna be a really big bag trigger for
her and Teddy was just learning kind of
what was the trigger and what lesson
yeah you know that's scary whose side
were you want Erica okay but we were on
Erica side just cuz honestly like we're
just such like my barracks for her she
can't do anything wrong and also I just
felt like Teddy wasn't stepping up to
the plate as I like in terms of she was
being too sensitive yeah and she was
honestly having too much of a normal
reaction when she needed to have like a
housewife reaction she mean it needed to
be bigger it needed to be fuller it
needed to be a little bit more dramatic
like felt so calm so when you when you
look at the Teddy interview but you're
like this isn't a bad sight but when you
look at Erica you're like oh [ __ ] like
Teddy crossed a line like oh my god so
it was getting coal to see that I I'm on
both of their sites I understand it I am
now I I've come to terms with that but
also something interesting season wonder
II like we were not here for it like oh
my god and honestly I think if we would
have supported her like not coming back
and season to like loved her season 2
and most people had the opposite
experience she got a pretty bad rap this
bassy [ __ ] kid and I don't think it was
earned like I thought I really liked her
the season I think it was the drinking
glass incident that just like oh we
won't drink it out of like a solo cup or
this and that she's actually a lot more
down-to-earth and that and I think
that's like a fun facade for dab it's
like a little quirk like I don't think
she's gonna like throw the drink on the
ground and be like get me another she
just like that's her thing like that's
her thing I love her hair she's gorgeous
and realized I love dedication she has
to her style and her glam and like she's
always serving looks like so is
arrogance that's like Erica's full-time
job also and dorita's does it for fun
which I really appreciate but like Erica
given her lessons on like how to like
sing 2pk is like that was a moment I
totally I mean when they were in there
like the first few episodes when they
were like getting along in Vegas like
there was nothing better yeah nothing I
didn't even realize how much I needed
their friendship jury would be the most
fun I think to like actually hang out
with and go out with agreed cuz Erica
well that would be so much fun and I
would kill to be in her squad I think I
think I would try and impress her way
too much because she's Erika Jayne wears
jury would be like chill like I bought a
t-shirt the other day because I saw a
doreet wearing that and I never do that
le garite's wearing it I have to buy a
black t-shirt it was it's something at
intermix and estou be an SS t-shirt it's
like she was wearing it in white I
bought in like army green and it's kind
of like ripped but it's cool that said I
was like wow so to read
speaking of West Coast Oasys coming back
soon yes it is what can we expect so I
think well did you like last season cuz
I felt like a lot of people didn't yeah
and I think it got a bad rap like all my
friends I'm gonna choose to blame Peggy
that's fair
Missy lehand I mean aya was never the
biggest OC fan like that was probably
the last one I kind of hitched a ride on
too even though it's the original
according to Andy he says this season is
much better like Vicki brings it it's
really got good chemistry it has good
drama so I'm just hoping that it kind of
pulls through because they did kind of
fine last season to be a little bit of a
bummer but it's only up from here okay
yeah and I love Kelly Dada and I can't
believe I'm saying that like she is so
she is she she texted she's someone else
had a major transformation like on the
show cuz after her first CD I was like
this woman is a liability she's evil she
was below the belt like they shouldn't
have to be around her and now I'm like
if you ever take Kelly off the show
do you like Meghan King Edmonds like I
only will forever love her because she
exposed Brooks yeah so she'll always be
good in my book but as a house always
like she she wasn't doing that much for
me yeah she was kind of she felt like
she was over it yes she was over it like
she had a lot going on she was like
between cities and I felt like just
spread thin and do you like Tamra I do
like Tamra and I love Tamra and Shannon
I love Shannon beador Shannon really
know Shannon I mean listen we saw what a
weekend there we saw a lot of issues
going on like she's she's the every is
like what real people are I totally
agree that they're they aren't real
people but it's easy to relate to
Shannon beador I feel like that's
something that everyone goes through
I completely agree and I really hope
that we see like the the Rhea Mansa
patient of Shannon beador
we there will be justice for Shannon
that makes me so happy also do you ever
think Heather Dubrow will return I don't
although that was definitely in the
ether for a while but I think I mean
listen she could make a comeback like
Bethenny where it's like you give it
three seasons and then all of a sudden
it's like you're really new and
interesting again yeah I think we have
to wait a little bit more time for that
to happen but I mean listen anything is
possible I think I think do you want her
to come back
I loved her okay I thought she brought
like a different touch to the OC and yes
always welcome but the show goes on
without her as well I love a brunette
yes I mean you're so Heather Dubrow
what housewife of all of the franchise's
and we were just talking about it yes
past week do you think deserves like a
second chance that you would like to see
come back so I saw this question come
through when I was really thinking about
it last night and I was like it's hard
to say because like I would love Jill
Zarin to kind of come back like I really
think it would be a very interesting
dynamic now having Dorinda here and all
the women have sort of grown up like to
see Jill kind of thrown in and we saw
her momentarily at Bobby's funeral which
was super sad this season you know who I
kind of really I like her but I don't
think she offered a lot was Kristen
taekman huh and the oh I see you judging
me Jackie and
no and we're since she won housewives
patiently no attractive okay so it's
like the lesbian coming out of me that
that's just like my own little thing
right very fair I'm not speaking for the
viewers here I know I'm not speaking for
you I get that I understand you know
there's a couple Jersey people like
sometimes I think like Deena or Caroline
just to throw it back in there would be
really really fun yeah I mean if Phaedra
came back that would be just a whole
other ball of wax because that was so
terrible how it ended so terrible so for
her that she that she could ever that I
don't because I don't think any of the
women want to be around her and you
can't really have a show we're like
you're so isolated as you said you
really need an ally on it at least one
person who's gonna speak up for you and
no one else is listening to you she
doesn't really have that yeah so it's
not gonna be everything that we want it
to be very fair who do you want to come
back we were talking about this in depth
and I I think a Brandi Glanville is the
shake is the kick in the pants that
Beverly Hills means
could you imagine you Brandi Glanville
came back but was on Real Housewives of
New York
like imagine her in Bethany no that's
what I that's what I want to see like I
just like I want to see back a house one
house I should move to a different city
and like join different franchise that
would be so interesting it's like a
wife's well yeah but that would be great
that's that was a great done done okay
what is the craziest or most elaborate
gift Andy has received from a broader
Liberty um a few years ago a few years
ago probably like five years ago we got
a box of vibrators from I think it was
like to celebrate when candy was doing
like I said I think noted nights and now
she has her own like Tasha I saw Daisy
for it it's literally so I spoke to her
last night she was um I spoke to her
last night and I was interviewing her
and I was like tell me some Goss what is
the juiciest thing and she said that
Erica Jane on the after show goes like
she is so freaky and like so spicy she's
worth spicy to me she's like you have to
see when is Eric on I don't think she's
the first episode I think she's like two
or three anybody but like definitely
watch the after show okay that's where
you like it's the web so you can go you
can go deeper than you can but she said
it was like on
and for candy to be saying that it's
crazy oh wow that's so exciting
that's a lot so I think because it was
either like in response to her coming on
air or maybe it was sent by her it was
legitimately 30 vibrators of like
high-end vibrators and I had to go into
a teas office and I was like do you do
you want these and he was like you know
what Darrin you can keep them and I gave
them to all of my friends and I just
like pass about like I was real like
$300 vibrators like passing him out one
of my friends says this was like five
six years ago ahead and never orgasm
before in her life and I gave her this
and I was like courtesy of me from Andy
Cohen to you and she went home that
night she's like dare I say that Andy
Cohen gave me my first orgasm Thank You
Larry and she's gay and I was like dad
needs to the title of your first book
that is amazing that's amazing
yes okay I have one final question for
you because we're out of time and it's
very random but something near and dear
to my heart
okay ladies of London yes will we ever
see it back and why did it end was it
only because Caroline noted about Dubai
I don't think that was the only reason I
think that you know ratings have a
factor fans have a factor I think
there's so much programming on Bravo
that other things just kind of trumped
it with Vanderpump rules in southern
charming seven Housewives franchises I
don't want to say never say never
because we always need to show abroad I
don't see it in the near future
okay it's got to come back and be like
retro and hip again I loved it so much
and I love Caroline I still follow her
like she's everything oh my god I'm
really not gonna forget Jackie your face
when I said Kristen taekman I hate I
take minute back because my god your
face I was just like I thought it would
be really like one of the like you know
the heavy hitters yo it was listen I
love it on her dog okay no your dog
I very much appreciate that um thank you
so much thanks very much I feel like I
get stuck so many more questions like
Jackson Britney or engage and I'm so
excited for a man and pepper rules very
excited about it it's going to be great
he told me he got a ring like six months
ago and he was just waiting to kind of
propose until we were back filming so he
had a ring a while and I appreciate him
doing that because like yeah he's in
tune with what's necessary if we if we
if they started the season they were
just engaged meaning got to see it like
that would be a bummer that wouldn't
have been fun at all he's smart he knows
what he's doing
we say that all the time and he's a
wonderful reality TV star yeah and did
you see that
the Columbus Zoo a monkey they named a
new monkey Jax Taylor after him no I did
oh you need to see that story that is in
your top 5 stories that's what you need
to do and it was named after I have any
like had tweeted at that there really
because we're such Vanderpump rules at a
zoo we're such 400 world stars like
we're gonna name a brand new monkey Jax
Taylor that's a person last name I was
like Kirsty lasting Percy lassie Darren
thank you so much for being here
everyone follow you listen to your
podcast etc at carpe Darrin for all of
my social handles martinis and murderers
at oxygen.com you can find it anywhere
you get your podcast and bravotv.com
slash weekly pregame thank you very much
thank you go enjoy your weekly pregame
right now it's only Thursday damn
tomorrow we are back with Lauren efforts
Bostic the skinny confidential I'm so
excited
and have a great day everyone I'm taking
Theo for a walk because it's Encinitas
day out
you